[Music]
I've known you for a long time and I was
thinking one of the biggest changes that
I've seen in you as a person came when
you got your dog and I remember you
approached it in very Tim Ferriss
fashion you didn't just like hey I like
me like I got a goat one day because we
saw it on Craigslist and we just like
when I got it but that's not what for
the Tim Ferriss way yeah you were like
you were taught you talked to a bunch of
people you read a bunch of books but you
ultimately end up was it 10 years ago
you got a dog four and a half years ago
okay but but it's been an interesting
pivot in your life why do you think it
it impacted you so much I think that
there are a few aspects to it
number one is caring for a puppy at
least if you do it well takes your
attention outside of any type of
self-indulgent reflection /
obsessive-compulsive rumination sure and
as someone who has had a history of
depression which is being stuck in the
past and I think being highly self
referential I mean it depression is I
think as someone who's experienced it a
lot in life very self obsessive yes when
you have something in front of you that
requires and demands care or it's gonna
pee on your carpet every two and a half
hours like Molly my dog it's incredibly
anti depressive in that sense because it
forces a complete refocus I also I think
realized very quickly how absurd some of
my reactions are to things or have been
historically in the sense that if you
have a problem at work you have a
problem with your partner your spouse
your girlfriend boyfriend you can get
upset and sort of create an imaginary
agenda that they have where they
deliberately did a B or C to upset you
sure but with a dog that's completely
absurd like at face value it's come
right so the problems are your fault
it's your fault right so if your dog
chews on your shoes that's your fault
it's a dog and you left your shoes out
that's so a big part of I think raising
a puppy well is making it extremely
difficult to make mistakes that then
become habits right that's that's that's
an approach or at least a lens through
which you can look at raising a puppy
and if you don't like your dog to
develop a taste for chewing on shoes
don't leave your shoes out put them on
something or in something that makes
that impossible
and similarly peeing in the house to
avoid that use something like crate
training and so I think that when I
became particularly in the early periods
of training Molly upset because she
wouldn't follow my instructions
yeah after an initial period of just
getting upset which i think was my
default it has been a default for a long
time anger is been a go-to emotion which
yeah I think is I think Krista Tippett
once said it's fear shown in public or
something like that which I tend to
agree with on some level getting upset
is fear shown in public getting angry
yeah yep and it's a coping mechanism
some people shut down right and people
learn to get angry I learned to get
angry like when I was when I was little
so doing that though with this dog who
does not speak English was so ridiculous
and ineffective that I had to resort to
doing other things that lo and behold
translate to other people and even to
yourself like positive reinforcement
yeah right I didn't through sports and
coaching and teaching or receiving
teaching that's a little bit of positive
reinforcement not not not a whole lot
yeah so I've learned to go without it
even though that is unhealthy sure and
reading about animal training if you
really want to take it seriously if you
look at say training marine mammals like
dolphins you can't get pissed and hit it
with a rolled-up newspaper it doesn't
work underwater and they're faster than
you are so you have to figure out how to
use like whistles
different clickers and means of marking
the desired behavior and then rewarding
sure and getting into the habit of
providing positive reinforcement I think
led to me doing that more I could could
still do it more with other people and
like how you treat other people
I think impacts how you treat yourself
and relate to yourself so I think that
those are all pieces of the puzzle and
last but not least feeling unconditional
love although granted very few giving
your dog food and treats helps a lot
yeah but feeling this love from an
animal and experiencing that in the
absence of language I think is really
powerful
yeah as someone as someone who tends to
get tangled in their own inner voice in
the form of language to experience that
type of deep positive emotion in
connection without language to trip over
has been really impactful for me do you
think it was sort of giving you
something to care about like to be
responsible for that wasn't there was
there's no there's no reason to have the
dog like you have the dog because you
love the dog what I mean like this
you're not getting anything out of it in
the sense of like sure you have a nice
car you have to take care of the nice
car but you know you know what I mean
yeah I think so I mean you won't you get
a dog because you want a dog it's in a
sense a very selfish act yeah even
though you can adopt and do all these
other things as I did with Molly that
one would hope have some positive karma
share back but ultimately you are
choosing to have a dog right similarly I
think having kids is this isn't a bad
thing it's not a value judgement but
like it is a selfish decision like you
have kids because you want to have kids
right yeah and I remember Mike maples
who's this very well-known investor and
friend of mine said to me he's like rule
number one with kids is like they owe
you nothing like their job is to receive
love not to give you love yeah because
you decided to have the kids right and I
think that's true to dogs as well or any
type of pet
and for that reason I do not recommend
that everybody get dogs right because I
think that for a lot of folks as I felt
for a really long time I was too self
focused slash obsessed and the only way
I could see having a dog was to kind of
wedge it into the open spaces that were
left over once I had already executed on
everything else I wanted to execute on
or fixate on and when I ended up getting
Molly I made the decision that I was
going to actually reverse that and get
Molly prioritize really taking good care
of her and then fit everything else
around the dog right and that's those
are two fundamentally different ways to
look at it and I think if you look at
sort of the realm of behavior in humans
and dogs like most animals including
humans are poorly trained yeah and to do
it well takes a lot of effort and
consistency so if someone's ready for
that then I I suggest you know adopting
ideally but otherwise I've seen people
who would get dogs and then just neglect
them sure
and I'm conflicted as to how to feel
about that because on one hand if
they're rescuing a dog from a kill
shelter probably better probably better
you one could argue that's better but I
don't know I'm not yeah I'm no
professional ethicists oh no there's a
there's a thing David Brooks talks about
when his son was born someone sent him
an email and said this is his first kid
they said you know like welcome to
unavoidable reality and the idea being
that up until you're up until then sure
you have responsibilities is work in
life but like pretty much anything you
don't want to have to put up but you
don't have to put up with right yeah as
soon as you take on something like that
like with a kid it's like you think okay
I'm gonna go to this thing at one
o'clock but if your kid falls asleep at
12:59 you're going to the thing when
your kid wakes up yeah and I think dogs
have an element of that too suddenly
you're responsible for this thing that
is totally dependent on you
No and the dog decides what the schedule
is not you which if you're successful or
self-absorbed and they're kind of the
same thing in different ways
it forces you to pivot your reality in a
way that makes you a better person I
think I think so and you develop I don't
I don't really want to use the word
patience I think it's something else
maybe greater self-awareness and
resilience in the face of the
unpredictable sequin enmity is what an
equanimity yeah equanimity we could use
because it's like alright Molly gets
sick I'll give you an example like I
remember one morning I woke up to the
most awful stench imaginable at like
4:00 in the morning right and I'm very
protective of my sleep historically
they're like one of the best ways to get
me really spun up and upset
it's like negatively affect my sleep
okay and it's like 4:00 in the morning I
went to bed at 1:00 yeah and this is the
most horrible stench you can imagine I
wake up a turn the light and Molly has
[ __ ] everywhere in the bedroom including
on the wall which I thought was very
impressive I'm like course what
possesses the dog yeah [ __ ] against the
wall I don't know nonetheless like
alright this is like this is what you're
dealing with they're not avoidable
reality our of two hours right putting
on your hazmat gear and dealing with
this and I think you develop or I have
developed to some extent I don't think
I'm the best at this but the ability to
put my better put myself in other
people's shoes sure because in a
situation like that it's clear to me
Molly doesn't want to do what she's
doing right there's something I do this
to ruin your sleep she's not going to
real nicely and it's it's it's not just
unhelpful but it's damaging to lose your
lose your husband say lose your [ __ ] but
to get really upset in a situation like
that it actually makes it harder to
train your dog effectively
you